Bitte, nehmt die Chips von mir weg -
ich will das nicht!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Ihr kennt das doch sicherlich auch:
Ihr habt gerade
ein fantastisches Mahl hinter euch.
Ihr fühlt euch voll,
wenn nicht sogar überfressen.
Doch dann
kommt jemand mit Kuchen daher.
Und Ihr denkt euch so:
Jooaaa...
Wie kommt es, dass wir manchmal
weiter und weiter essen,
obwohl wir kurz vorm Platzen sind?
Erstmal vielleicht:
wie funktioniert Appetit eigentlich?
Sobald unser Magen leer ist,
wird ein Hormon
namens Ghrelin ausgeschüttet,
das uns ein Verlangen
nach Essen spüren lässt.
Deswegen
oft "Hunger-Hormon" genannt,
greift der Name
z.T. ein bisschen zu kurz.
Ghrelin ist gewissermaßen
auch ein Stresshormon,
das uns Ausdauer und Willenskraft
in erschwerten Situationen verleiht.
Get that shit together! - Ja, okay.
Wenn wir dann etwas zu futtern
bekommen, sinkt der Ghrelin-Spiegel,
und ein anderes Hormon
betritt die Bühne, nämlich Leptin.
Die Rolle von Leptin
ist es, uns zu sagen:
- Du bist satt!
Ahem!
Unser Körper ist also eigentlich
mit einem perfekten
Kontrollmechanismus ausgestattet,
der uns sagt, wann wir essen
und wann wir aufhören sollen.
Wieso bitten wir dann
trotzdem andere Menschen,
uns die Chipstüte wegzunehmen,
weil wir uns selbst
nicht kontrollieren können?
Essen, das viel Fett
und/oder Zucker beinhaltet,
empfinden wir
als besonders schmackhaft,
weil es uns
besonders viel Energie liefert.
Bei unseren Vorfahren machte das
noch Sinn, dass der Körper
besonders energiereiche Nahrung
als besonders begehrenswert empfand.
Zu Zeiten der Jäger und Sammler,
wo man quasi Tag für Tag
ums Überleben kämpfen musste.
Heute kann man sich kaum retten
vor fett-
und zuckerhaltigen Lebensmitteln.
Da haben wir mal wieder
den klassischen Fall,
das sich unsere Umwelt schneller
verändert hat als unsere Evolution.
Wissenschaftler sprechen manchmal
von "Hedonistischem Hunger",
der vergleichbar impulsiv sein soll
wie Drogenkonsum oder Glücksspiele.
Bei fett-
und zuckerhaltigen Lebensmitteln
werden Endorphine
und Dopamin ausgeschüttet.
Die sorgen für Euphorie
und bespielen das Belohnungssystem.
So können andere hormonelle Signale,
die mit dem Sättigungsgefühl
zusammenhängen, untergraben werden.
Je mehr zucker- und fetthaltige
Lebensmittel wir essen,
desto eher besteht die Gefahr,
dass wir gegenüber unseren körper-
eigenen Hormonantworten abstumpfen.
Die Regulierung durch Ghrelin
und Leptin wird immer ineffektiver,
wodurch wir
immer mehr Junk-Food essen.
Ein Teufelskreis.
Im Umkehrschluss
heißt das allerdings,
dass wir
umso weniger Junk-Food verlangen,
je weniger wir davon essen.
Macht Hoffnung, oder?
Schönschlau!
Wie geht es euch:
Seid ihr auch hedonistische Esser,
oder habt Ihr
vielleicht sogar gute Tipps,
wie man der Schoko-Torte
oder der Chipstüte widerstehen kann?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare,
zusammen mit euren Fragen.
Wir sehen uns nächstes Mal.